good morning John I have good news for
people who like me singing songs song
Wednesdays are returning from now until
the end of 2010 I'll be doing a new song
every single Wednesday I'm doing this
because I have song stuck in my head and
it's hard to get them out unless I am
very motivated to do so and so I am
motivating myself through nerdfighteria
I need you to motivate me
this song is a companion song to a video
I made a little bit of while ago a
little bit of while ago doesn't make any
sense
I do hope you enjoy this in 1950 at los
alamos I just was talking with his
friends and the conversation had them
all fully engrossed about this universe
that almost has no end and and they were
all about each other study Enrico
suddenly shouting where is everybody and
he sat down and did a few simple
calculations that indicated we should've
hit into the house at some time at least
based on his estimation
the Fermi paradox if they're out there
why don't hear about the galaxy just
keep talking with 400 billion stars in
it nights can't believe that we could be
unique when there's so much space in
this galaxy Oh our Pandora's box to be
open but instead we're stuck in curtains
paradox there are dozens of ways this
paradigm could be resolved and you
probably can think I'm suck yourself
maybe if it's technology you're rarely
the balls or maybe God sent them how the
hell or maybe that technology lead to
its own destruction or maybe species
lose interest in reproduction or maybe
they're just afraid of what we'll do
when we find out so they're hiding until
we grow of it and don't have this agency
to frequently freak out
oh that's the Fermi paradox if they're
out there why don't they talk the galaxy
just keep some slitted with 2 billion
stars in it and I just can't believe
that we could be unique when there's so
much space in this galaxy Oh a Pandora's
box to be open but instead we're stuck
in Fermi's paradox
well the question of whether there is
well I thought that as far as I'm
concerned is moot but it appears that
the aliens do 90s Foursquare and now I'm
not trying to be cute because the way
that we listen is defined by our ears
and the time that we've been listening
just a couple of years we'll be lucky
when we see them if we notice them at
our public phone could be ringing off
the hook right now the news not
answering a call
although that's a Fermi paradox they're
out there I done they top the galaxy
just came up with hundred billion stars
on I just can't believe that we could be
unique when there's so much space in
this galaxy oh how I adore us box to be
in the but instead we're stuck in
Fermi's paradox oh yeah we're stuck in
paradise on our stove Cooper's paradox
yeah stop it Bernice paradox
us I'm excited about the return of song
Wednesdays I hope that you are too if
you don't like nerdy songs there's
nothing I can do for you because I can't
stop writing John I will see you on
Friday